first take a deep yoga breath and ask
yourself how much do I really care about
doing this and how much strength am I
willing to lay on the table to stick
with it because there's just simply no
business not you know Oprah Winfrey's
business not Milton Hershey's business
not John Rockefellers business not Steve
Jobs as business that isn't at its
essence a story of extraordinary
persistence and faith and so the first
question I would say is how much do you
want it and how much strength and faith
will you lay down in pursuit of that
because you're going to need a lot
second lesson it takes an enormous
amount of commercial imagination
particularly in a cynical and
complicated and confusing moment like
our own it takes a great amount of
imagination of you know entertaining
conjecture as Shakespeare once said of
what might be to build a new enduring
successful business and so look a look
around turn yourself upside down walk
all around the business problem or the
opportunity keep your eyes open and
don't default to the word on the street
or the word in the media or the word
that's coming down from what goes for
leadership today think for yourself and
look broadly and look wildly imagine all
kinds of possibilities thirdly what
think very clearly about what are the
most important dreams and ambitions that
you have because your dreams are the
business you know it's so interesting
estate entrepreneur entrepreneurs and
their journeys for 20 years and for the
first five or six years of the of the
enterprise or of the journey everything
about the business depends on the
conversations that the entrepreneur has
with him or herself so you need to get
right with yourself as an entrepreneur
over and over again about what really
matters to you and then realize that
materialize it pull it out of the ether
and into a product or an offering and
you
to do that as much inside yourself as in
the garage and with your investors and
with your small team or the American
economy has always depended on
entrepreneurial spark on the kindling of
entrepreneurs that eventually get set
fire into great economic growth we have
never needed it more than we do right
now and so there's a great calling here
for entrepreneurs and and remember that
as you as you walk your path and I think
that think very long and hard about
which who are the people and the
businesses that you admire because
entrepreneurship is not it's not a
venture that one undertakes in a
completely de novo way you do it by
cutting and pasting and mixing and
matching and borrowing always borrowing
from other great people and their ideas
and what's out there already and what's
not out there so don't be afraid to do
lots of cutting and pasting from your
most idealistic parts as you go along
and as you as you walk your path
a couple of things to think about is you
think about getting the idea into
something more tangible first find a
group of friends and colleagues and some
folks that you aren't sure like you too
much and create a small doesn't need to
be more than three to six people a small
mini board of directors that you can
test the idea with and talk to people
about talking about is the first really
important step to you know kind of
giving it life and it's important to
pick people that you know will if you
will kind of you know give you grief
because you want some people to test it
that will help your confidence it will
help the idea it will help the business
plan it will really add some gas and win
to your wings so the first step is
creating a small group of people that
some of which may be involved in the
business going forward but can really
serve as a kind of you know said of
constantly consoling gaiety for you
second step take go out and if it and
snoop around and spend some real time
and maybe a little money in the market
that you want to play so if you're
thinking about a new kind of retail
outlet or a new kind of website or new
kind of way of selling spend a lot of
time in that market literally think of
it as part of your job shopping mystery
shopping whether you buy anything or not
spending time on the internet the more
stakes you put in the ground one by one
again the more energy you're giving the
idea the more power so I would say if
you're interested in distribution get
someone you know to help create on the
cheap ideally for free a website that
you can experiment with it you can test
thirdly talk to a few people that you
know that have had some investment
experience it doesn't have to be
anything very fancy or very big but
people that know something about betting
on businesses with their money or other
people's money even just one person they
will give you amazingly good advice very
early on about two important things
first whether they think the idea is
interesting
and worthy but much more important much
more important than that because you
already as the entrepreneur will have
tested this with yourself and talk to
your your colleagues and friends and
enemies about so you'll have some sense
of that but the more important aspect of
talking to someone that has some
experience investing is that they will
tell you they will give you a good sense
of how very easy it really is to raise
money for good ideas this is great myth
that once you have an idea there's no
way to kind of fund its test its its
birthing process its entry into the
world with you as the Midwife but that's
a myth there's always money for good
ideas there's always energy and there's
always talent so it's almost it's almost
spiritual it's like we actually have
everything we need if we're an
entrepreneur with a good idea and a big
kind of leap of faith there's Lewbert
would say a busload of faith there's
always the enablers but but we need to
have different if you will angels or you
know Gabriel's showing us the way to
that abundance and these kind of steps
help help entrepreneurs you know get get
a sense of that and then get some energy
and some and some specific signposts for
taking this thing out of the ether and
into the garage
finding the investors is is primarily a
detective pursuit it's primarily and it
begins with the people that you know and
the people that they know and then one
more degree out the people that those
people now so it really begins there and
it's it's it's just it's as if you're
looking for your first job and all
you're really doing is just following
these threads these bread crumbs of
people that know people that know people
and that is like panning for gold again
you know screw your courage to the
sticking post it may take a little bit
of time but you have to keep panning and
you have to stay at it because there are
some people in your network in your
circle in three degrees out that are
interested they may or may not invest
but they're interesting and if they
don't invest they may know someone that
does so so the first thing is to settle
in to what's going to be a web of
nuggets that you're going to follow in
lots of haphazard in a few more logical
ways second realize that secondly you're
going to have to be able to describe
your idea pretty succinctly and
powerfully at the same time so this is
when again we're cursing this writing it
down then reading it or and eventually
saying it to people running this by all
the different people in your circle
particularly a board of directors and
informal board of directors can be very
very useful we like to call this the
elevator pitch you're standing in the
elevator you have five minutes with a
venture capitalist between floors what
do you say and and everyone needs an
elevator pitch for whatever one is
passionate at that and so in five to
eight sentences with a good first
sentence that's a topic sentence what is
the idea and why does it matter that is
something you can home late at night in
the bathtub walking back from the subway
you know on the internet emailing to
friends but you want to spend some real
time on an elevator pitch and thirdly
then once you have a succinct summary of
what you're up to you want to stand in
front of a mirror and say it you're
saying it to yourself as much as you're
saying to any prospective investors but
but how we present ourselves and how we
present what comes
boss it's very important it's not just
important for what we might get from it
out externally it's important for how we
think about ourselves and for bringing
some of the best parts of ourselves into
the light so follow the bread crumbs of
your connection figure out what your
elevator pitches and don't worry if that
takes some time and thirdly then
rehearse it and say it to yourself and
then to a larger world